Cori,
what about you,
do you think it could have evolved in an
entirely different way and retain some
of that openness and sense of boundless
freedom there?
Well,
I mean,
I'm not a historical determinists,
so yes,
of course,
lots of different things could have
happened.
Yeah,
I mean I believe in the adjacent
possible so people have ideas for things
like airplanes at periodic intervals
through the whole of human history.
But eventually some of those ideas get
realized because we have material
science and physics to kind of catch up
with it,
which is what,
when people say you get railroads when
it's railroading time,
they don't mean that there's a mystical
railroading energy in the air.
They just mean that we have now attained
the point where when that idea occurs
with it's on scheduled regularity,
that's some of the people to whom it
occurs will be able to figure out how to
make it a reality.
So I don't think we run on rails.
I think we have lots of moments in our
history where things have gone well and
somewhere they've gone poorly.
When the robot web consortium,
uh,
decided that members who participated in
standard setting would have to have your
web patents,
so there would be no tollgates for
producing web technology.
That was a key juncture.
I could have gone a different way.
It could have been much worse.
But on the other hand,
when the Digital Millennium Copyright
Act was passed in 98,
and when the European Union copyright
directive was passed in 2001,
both of them produce extraordinarily bad
policy that if we hadn't had it,
I think things would be much better.
They both provide for,
among other things,
an unaccountable system of arbitrary
censorship and a rule prohibiting a
disclosing security vulnerabilities in
technologies that we rely on which could
have produced,
uh,
which,
which does present a clear and present
danger to us.
Which is only gonna get worse unless we
can do something about it.